[Musik]
bismarck erst ist die blm unique werde
am ende dieser sitzung also ich werde
die ich werde nur bis zu halb halb zwei
sprechen damit ich dann die protokolle
besprechen kann
und ich habe auch hinweise für diejenige
die protokoll schreiben wollen wie viele
gibt es hier die protokoll machen aber
dann habe ich reichlich genug falls sie
jemanden kennen der nicht die nicht hier
ist und protokolle schreiben möchte
können sie dann ein exemplar für diese
studenten nehmen
ich sollte sie wahrscheinlich auch dann
hochladen und weil ich weil ich
vergessen habe
das daraus zu schreiben sei jetzt soll
sich das wieder vergessen dass die
protokolle das sollen sie drauf
schreiben ob sie eine note brauchen oder
nicht also bald manchmal braucht man das
bedeutet manchmal braucht man nur
bestanden nicht bestanden
und ich muss wissen ob ich eine note
ausdenken muss oder nicht
und auch voraus wollte ich sagen da in
dieser verletzungsserie decken wir sehr
viel für die situation ab als ich ein
altes schiff lust wie natürlich die
frühe moderne islamische schloss sich
die letzte woche haben wir in dem spiel
das wie nächste woche haben afrikanische
flosse die und diese woche chinesischen
fluss wie von diesen traditionen ist
china dass es die tradition wo ich mich
am wenigsten auskenne
um das bild auszudrücken
in den anderen fällen
ist das entweder service war meine
vorstellung gebiets also islamischen bin
ich relativ würde ich sagen aber es ist
bei afrikanischen und indischen plus tih
ich habe eine ganze reihe von podcast
folgen dazu geschrieben oder
mitgeschrieben mit einem kurator ich
habe vor in der zukunft dass china zu
machen
ich habe sogar eine eine mit autoren die
mit mir in der pluscity hat dahin wird
kein live als auch sein
das haben wir noch alle noch nicht
erreicht das wird erst nach
afrikanischer führer sie kommen und von
daher bin ich mein ich bin kein fachmann
für indische slow city oder
afrikanisches wie aber da kenne ich mich
aus dass ich heute sagen werde das habe
ich wirklich nur für diese vorlesung
gelehrt also erstens an sie bitte
verzeiht bezeichnen sie mich wenn ich
fehler mache
zweitens wenn ich antworte wer nicht
fragen nicht beantworten kann
und drittens sollen sie alles was sie
jetzt hören in praktisch mit sternchen
im kopf schreiben könnte der fall sein
aber vielleicht nichts
wobei also ab und so werde ich einfach
aus den krallen zitieren und das ist
relativ sicher dass das gesagt haben wir
das ja das aus guten büchern gehört aber
ich muss sagen dass ich war wirklich
begeistert das zu machen weil
chinesische sie unglaublich interessant
ist und an meines erachtens wirklich ein
dritter also ich sehe ein titel also
wieso das antike verlasse sie drei
strände hat sozusagen
ich fliege schildläuse die indische und
chinesische für das die und die sind
alle gleich hinter gesagt könnte man
sagen chinesische flüssig ist ist sogar
im vergleich zu diesen andere
installationen besonderes für unser
thema interessant war chinesisch was die
flecken immerhin so stark sagen dass so
stark in sachen ethik und kritisch über
das so wir haben jetzt sehr ausführlich
ethische philosophie in der chinesischen
tradition beziehungsweise mehrere
traditionen die habe mit ethik zu tun
haben aber in der menge denkt man
natürlich an konfuzianismus und ist
wirklich eine interessante frage ob und
inwiefern konfuzianische floh sie eine
tierethik beinhalten könnte oder wenn
nicht ob diese flüsse sie tätig
infizieren könnte in der indischen
koalition liegt das auf der hand weil
wir gesehen haben haben sie diese ganze
terry der ams also nicht gewalt und wer
also sie ihren vegetarismus mit in
dienten sehr stark und zu recht werden
wir das mit china nicht tun also wenn
wir an chinesisches essen denken denken
wir nicht in der ersten jahren
vegetarisches essen um das bild
auszudrücken
und in der tat war ist auch nicht der
fall
das konfuzianische flüsse wie sich für
vegetarismus stark gemacht hat oder
dafür argumentiert hat wie wir sehen
werden sogar bei den neo konvention war
es der fall dass sie sehr stark für
fürsorge und mitleid für tiere
argumentiert haben aber soweit sie nicht
gegangen dass die vegetarier geworden
sind eine interessante frage werde
natürlich ob das was mit buddhismus zu
tun hat nicht dass alle polizisten
vegetarier sind aber ab der als was du
uns der spätantike ist also im vor allem
glaube ich nach dem ab dem sechsten
jahrhundert oder so wird das muss in der
indischen endlos wie sehr präsent und es
gibt konkurrenz zwischen den
einheimischen viele solchen schulen die
schon in china anwesen bahn beim tarif
muss in gröden für tourismus und dann
buddhismus dass sein der neue partner
und die bilden dann die drei haupt
traditionen der chinesischen börse die
geschichte da die buddhisten natürlich
diese dieser effekt von amr hatten war
das eine herausforderung für die schon
anwesende tradition china und das ist
ein beispiel wo ich genug auskenne aber
es wäre eine plausible vermutung dass
diese buddhistische tätig dann
einerseits die einheimische schulen
beeinflusst hat andererseits an dass
diese einheimische schulen nicht so weit
gehen wollten dass sie so sein gedicht
es geworden sind aber das nur wie gesagt
an der vermutung
indien gemacht habe wollte ich damit
anfangen dass sich kurz die geschichte
der philosophie in china skizziere das
ist eine sehr lange geschichte
natürlich also geht komplett darauf an
was man alles für die social text
erzählt aber mindestens bis zum 12 100
jahre vor christus also sehr weiter so
wir haben mit mehr als 3000 jahre der
philosophie zu tun und um das mindeste
zu sagen kann ich das jetzt nicht
ausführlich beschreiben
erstens weiß so viel zu sagen gibt und
zweitens weil ich keine ahnung habe
also die keine ahnung das was ich dafür
dieses ist um gelesen habe hat
hauptsächlich mit der antiken nation
inklusive zu tun
aber natürlich gibt es einen nachleben
für konfuzianismus da riss muss und
buddhismus dessen heutigen tag in china
die der körper für dich als 500 vor
christus genannt habe als möglicher
anfang wahrscheinlich könnte man noch
mal zurücklehnen ist dass wir an das
team übrigens aussprache müssen wir gar
nicht sagen aber aussprache wird welt
falsch sein
ja ich meine sogar schon bei salzgitter
aber das wird viel weiter von der
richtigen ansprache ableiten heißt es
bei stunts wird der fall war und das war
schlimm genug gute nachricht in zwei
wochen sind wir bei arabischen texten
und das kann nicht richtig aussprechen
oder besser mit es besser ansprechen
dieses buch nieding ein buch der
veränderung ist die inspiration oder
eine inspiration für die späte reaktion
des daoismus das verbinden wir natürlich
vor allem mit laut der im vierten
jahrhundert das bekannte dating
geschieden hat und in diesem buch haben
wir unter anderem mit denen wie
gegenüberstanden von jene und jan zu tun
und die idee von key
und diese zwei den wollte ich kurz
erwähnen weil sie dann später vorkommen
werden wenn wir tiere bestatten den &
young
das ist natürlich ein begriff oder
doppel begriff was jeder kennt das ihr
mir keine klischee dass wir ihnen und
jagen mit chinesischer philosophie
verbindet verwenden und wir kennen alle
dieses bild schwarz und
das ist von dem was ich gelesen habe
mich ganz irreführend das bild weil jene
union wirklich mit licht und dunklen und
finsternis und leid zu tun haben also
jene ist dunkelheit young ist das helle
und ursprünglich hieß das sogar einfach
ein ein flackerndes also young war ein
fleck in der sonne zum beispiel auf
einem hügel young ist vielleicht in der
sonne
gnss flecken schatten und wenn man an
dieses beispiel denkt nicht und dunkel
das sieht man sofort die hauptidee
nämlich dass diese zwei phänomene
zusammenkommen müssen weil nicht braucht
sozusagen kontrast dunkelheit damit das
überhaupt sinnvoll ist und diese
gegenüberstellung von licht und
dunkelheit wird dann zunehmend dann
breite und abstrakter verstanden und das
ist diejenige dass wir diese zwei
ausgleichende und komplett komplementäre
kräfte oder tendenzen oder phänomene in
der welt immer wieder haben zum beispiel
das harte und das weiche sind noch ein
beispiel für jan und hier also dass
langes typischerweise das kraftvolle
also das was vor drängt und deswegen
auch das hatte also das was unser würde
das unser antasten irgendwie
konfrontiert zu sagen und yen natürlich
das gegenteil und auch werden wir sehen
dass die in den tier theorien haben wir
die idee dass young dass es was bindet
oder zusammenbringt von ihm ist das was
erteilt wurde umgekehrt glauben zu
sorgen
aber hauptsache ist dass sie sich
ausgleichen und kompetent arisch immer
zusammen kommen ein zweites idee ist die
von key lebenskraft und wir sehen werden
ist das eine wichtige theorie noch mal
um tiere zu verstehen weil wiki ist ein
dass es ein phänomen was bei menschen
und tieren vorkommt und das was ist es
was das sehr gut und herren gemeinsam
haben
mehr dazu in ein paar minuten
das ist auch sehr wichtig in der medizin
und ist leicht vorsichtig mit theorien
aus der europäischen situation zu
vergleichen die wir schon besprochen an
und die wieder zur sprache kommen werden
diese theorien über kleiner also dieses
dieses spiritus oder heiße luft was die
was den körper kontrolliert oder steuert
diese rolle spielt in der chinesischen
medizin und genau wie heime und andere
flüssigkeiten in den körper gesundheit
und krankheit verursachen oder gedanken
spielt die eine ähnliche rolle in der
chinesischen medizin
das ist übrigens ein beispiel weil ich
würde sagen dass sie mindestens oft wenn
mit vorwiegend in medizinischen texten
vorkommt früheren der tradition und das
ist ein beispiel wie ein tier
besprechungen in theorien über tiere und
philosophen wissenschaftler
beschränkungen von medizin und
gesundheit zusammenhängen
das werden wir noch mal in der
islamischen islamischen kontext sehen
müssen nächste woche im afrikanischen
kontext city wenn man daran denkt dass
dies sinnvoll dass das was wir
offensichtlich mit tieren gemeinsam
haben ist natürlich dass wir lebende
körper sind genau wie tiere
und unsere tiere sind auch ähnlich zu
tierkörper und haben deswegen bleibt die
gleiche prinzipien zum beispiel diese
lebenskraft und das ist genau was diese
texte dann sagen werden
ok neben doris muss gibt es dann mehrere
andere philosophische schulen sollte ich
so genannte schule der namen die mehr
mit beschluss widersprachen logik zu tun
hat und für uns heute nicht so richtig
ist aber auch es muss nach nutzer der im
vierten jahrhundert vor christus
gestorben ist
und natürlich konfuzianismus und nochmal
natürlich geht konfuzianismus von der
lehre konfuzius aus man fühlt sich das
heißt noch mal falsch ausgesprochen
kommt sie oder kommt sie und
traditionell wird das gesagt dass er 479
ortes ist sterben nutzer dann ungefähr
ein jahrhundert später angeblich haben
laut und konfuzius sich kennengelernt
und getroffen und konnte es hat über
laut gesagt er war
nein ich wie ein drache ob das ein
kompliment ist oder nicht kann ich
nichts sagen aber beide schulen
berichten von diesen treffen dass die
zwei hatten
das ist natürlich sehr spannend weil
diese zwei denke konfuzius an dazu uns
mit maria und buddha indien die auch
angeblich um die gleiche zeit gelebt
haben und plattform hat es dort nicht
alle fast gleichzeitig gelebt haben was
man immer mit stammen gemerkt und dann
nicht
man kann also die wetterlage war sehr
gut
ich persönlich gehe davon aus dass das
zufall ist aber ist auf jeden fall
interessant also viertel jahrhundert vor
christus gutes jahrhundert würde ich so
etwas wie uns konfis es ist auch wenn
vielleicht wenn sie nur eine tatsache
oder 1 1 botschaft von dieser vorlesung
mitnehmen für das restliche leben wenn
man sie fragt was ist das
einflussreichste buch der geschichte für
city nicht sehr einflussreich dir denke
vielleicht das natürlich schwer zu sagen
da es dort mills ist es so klar aber nur
ein buch dann ist so weit weg weiß mit
abstand gibt es nur eine antwort nämlich
die sogenannte ana legten von konfuzius
sie über jahre jahrhunderte hinweg ein
haupttext zum beispiel in der indischen
bürokratie war also dass das ist oder
das heißt jeder der beamte werden musste
das deutsche beschreiben ich bin beamter
also wenn ich wenn ich lese beamter
gewesen wäre hätte ich diana lebten
auswendig lernen müssen und das war eine
regierung die mehr als 1000 jahre
gedauert hat also seit dem
konfuzianismus dann sich angedeutet hat
in unserer der spätantike bis zum 20
jahrhundert und natürlich ist der fall
ist könnte sie zu netzen muss nicht
hundert plate sondern auch andere
asiatische länder zum beispiel
korea japan also die dass dieses kleine
buch ist wahrscheinlich das
meistgelesene und dass wir kommen das
reichste buch der geschichte der für das
ist wie gesagt mit abstand jemand hat
einen konter vorschlag aber das sage ich
einfach so weil es interessant ist also
wenn jemand fragt wenn jemand sie fragt
was ist das berühmte das wichtigste buch
in der geschichte des computers
was ist das heißt es natürlich irgendwie
erst dass man in fast allen europäischen
universitäten und in nordamerika flosse
die abschluss haben kann ohne eine seite
von konfuzius gelesen zu haben sehen wie
seltsam aber bevor er zu polemisch werde
werde ich versuchen die das licht könnte
lange tradition oder mindestens bis zum
zwölften jahrhundert zu beschreiben
es gibt zwei denke innerhalb der
kommissarischen tradition die nach
konfuzius kommen und sehr prägend sind
für die westliche tradition nämlich 19
wenn sie es sonst ja ja die die daten
haben sie auf dem handy bentzius wie wir
in europa sagen ist 289 volk ist schon
und zwar etwa 200 1 richter vor christus
gestorben
also wollte bemerkt wir sind hier immer
noch in der zeit der elastischen
philosophie
das ist höhepunkt von zum beispiel
stories muster für tourismus wir sind
noch nicht bei zum beispiel tennis muss
und dann nach einer langen zeit wo
können wir sehen dass immer mehr wie
gesagt als haupt für das hessische
schule in china erwartet und nachdem
buddhistische ideen dann reinkommen
haben wir die entstehung des sogenannten
neo konfuzianismus und das kommt dann
viel später also 15 40 jahrhundert nach
christus und zwei denke die ich dann am
ende der vorlesung erwähnen werde sind
chang auch und xu xin helfen uns sollten
jahrhundert nach christus allein daran
also wie dass wir mehrere wichtige
antike denker im halb konfuzianismus und
dann sozusagen einen neuanfang in
unserem mittelalter sieht man das noch
mal dass klose kommt ähnlich kompliziert
ist wie europäische philosophie also es
gab schulen die innerhalb der schule
streit geführt haben wie wir sind wie
wir sein werden es sind die
hauptstädtische lehrerin von menschen
gegeneinander
die agenten gegeneinander boxen sind
genau die gegenteilige auffassung von
menzels wenn es um menschliche natur
geht also es gab innerhalb jeder schule
die möglichkeit oder soll also reichlich
die möglichkeit für streit
und dass sie nicht einfach immer wieder
die gleiche lehre dunbar weiter
vermittelt haben
und dann gibt es noch dazu mehrere
schulen die gegeneinander krieg führen
können wie wir sehen werden an sind die
konvention sehr gegen morris muss das
ist wahrscheinlich ein grund warum neues
muss dann lang
ok so vieles im allgemeinen bild ich
werde jetzt nichts fragen ob sie
allgemeine fragen chinesischer city
haben weil die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ich sie beantworten kann so gering ist
aber vielleicht war ich trotzdem hat
niemand eine brennende ja das kommt
später aber das ist 3d sind an
aber stimmt das ich wollte kurz sagen
die uns verbindet man oft mit einer
telepathische und italien hat theorie so
dass eigentlich eine politische
philosophie und die idee ist dass der
herrscher aber auch jede einzelne person
das machen soll was das dass der für die
ganze gesellschaft ist und wie wir sein
werden sind die kommenden jahr
vielleicht überraschende weise dagegen
wir sagen nein das ist falsch er soll
nicht an das wohl der gesellschaft
denken sondern an einzelne beziehungen
die wir haben die wir richtig
kultivieren müssen und pflegen müssen
es war eine frage die ich sogar
beantworten konnte ok damit wir das
nicht verschreien
damit ich das ist verschieden mache ich
einfach weiter ok tiere also ich werde
zwei hauptthemen des gitarren erstens
werde ich ein bisschen über könnte man
von seinem wissenschaftlichen kriterien
sind sie tieren sagen und dann werde die
konfuzianische auffassung der tierethik
dann besprechen oder beziehungsweise die
frage steinhart ihr hättet überhaupt im
komplett sie das traditionsfest
vorkommen kann
wie würde das ausschauen erstens kann
man bemerken dass wir in der früh
tradition keine so logische werke haben
die männer des ortes zoologie
vergleichbar sind also grob könnte man
sagen die alten haben sowohl die gehabt
die chinesen nicht wobei sofort anfangen
muss das ist es nicht also wir sehr
viele so logische texte aus der antike
als antiker europa haben haben ein
vitales dort ist also jetzt anders
lautendes wert legt die ausnahme
und es gibt nicht so viele andere antike
autoren die seien so logisches projekt
dann weiter treiben oder entwickeln das
sind wir eher in dem im mittelalter in
der arabischen und dann in der
lateinischen tradition und es gibt sogar
ab und zu die idee das ist das archiv
die vermutung mindestens dass sie
ausdrücklich dagegen sind dass man sich
so viel mit ihr körper oder tierarten
beschäftigt zum beispiel gibt es einen
zugegeben etwas späteren text aus der
han-dynastie fängt ab dem dritten
jahrhundert nach christus an und die
dieser text ist der der weise also dafür
dass hof so sich mit tier hat nicht
beschäftigen
die hinweise dass diese weise sind damit
beschäftigt ihr hatten zu erklären was
erklären hier heißt es eine interessante
frage vielleicht einfach dass er nicht
die mühe geben muss um die einzelne
eigenschaften der tiere herauszufinden
wodurch man tieren unterscheiden kann
war das ist einfach nicht so interessant
dass die aber dass
philosophen gar keine gedanken über
tiere machen sollen dass es wirklich
nichts erfahren
also das heißt es nichts mit diversen
amt für das offene sehr viel zu sagen
wenn es um tiere geht oft im
zusammenhang von ethik der menschheit
aber auch um tierkörper also entwicklung
der tierkörper gemeinsam gemeinsam
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen menschen und
herren also das versprechen sich schon
und oft genau hin
mit diesen ideen die wir schon bei
daraus muss dann erwähnt haben
juni an und auch eine theorie die boxing
heißt das heißt fünf phasen oder vom
zustande
das ist eine theorie die in der ersten
linie uns an die 4 elements terry aus
den amtlichen rennen wird so sie wissen
die alten hatten vor allem mp cam
paddock ries hat man diese idee
es gibt vier elemente feuer erde wasser
luft und alle körper die wir erleben
vielleicht mit ausnahme der
himmelskörper vielleicht nichts sind
entstehen aus diesen vier elementen in
china wir sind ein bisschen besser die
fünf elemente aber beide sind besser als
die 70 weil dann hatten sie neue twin
den fire
manche erinnern sich bestimmt an den
feiern ja okay danke sehr gut weg
okay die und diese diese fünf phasen
teddy wie sollte hat fünf elemente
nämlich holz feuer erde metall und
wasser und eine idee dass sie dass sie
durch diese dynamische gegenüberstellung
von jenen und jahren auseinander
dann entwickeln können also holz kann
kann natürlich feuer werden durch
einfluss von ja und dass das kann auch
rückwärts gehen genau wie die vier
elemente in der griechischen theorie
ineinander verwandeln kann
dass es irgendwie man könnte vielleicht
sogar sagen eine empirische theorie zum
beispiel dass wenn man holz brennt da
hat man vorher und dann herrsche ok holz
feuer erde irgendwie naheliegend oder in
der griechen terry das wasser luft
werden kann
das kann man leicht beobachten einfach
ein bisschen besser auf meinem tisch
ausschütten warten und dann wird uns das
und wird läuft ja aber genau wie in
ungarn wird diese dann sehr sehr breit
aufgestellt und sehr sehr verschiedenen
kontexten hergenommen und
interessanterweise für uns ist eine es
ist ein beispiel dass man angeblich fünf
arten von tieren hat findet die mit den
fünf elementen der fünf phasen theorie
korreliert werden und diese für diese
vier arten von tieren sind die schuppige
gefährdete nachtessen wir unter anderem
haarige ohren es waren ich bin nachts
nichts gehört
haarige und gepanzert ihre kampagne wie
glaube ich also schildkröten so genau
und vielleicht hunger und das ist das
ist mehr als ein abstraktes vergleich
man im allgemeinen vielleicht hat man
schon geahnt dass dieses dieser diese
tendenz die wir auch bei den japanischen
festgestellt haben zum beispiel wurde
gesehen haben dass die kosmologie mit
oder dass der kosmos mit dem körper
eines pferdes verglichen würde also
diese diese tendenz ähnlichkeiten oder
hanno lienen zwischen mehreren systemen
oder mehreren phänomene phänomene zu
so ziehen womit man zeigen konnte dass
es das eine struktur zweimal vorkommt
also zum beispiel im kosmos die hund in
dem tierkörper das sind wir hier auch
auf jeden fall zum beispiel sind die 5
sie haben auch fünf saison sind nicht
wir spät sondern ist auch eine saison
und diese fünf songs werden auch mit den
elementen korreliert ist interessante
fragen jedenfalls nachzudenken
wir haben
ob die ob die elemente irgendwie diese
sonst verursachen oder nichts aber in
dem fall von den tieren ja war die die
schuppen werden felder noch mal durch
einfluss von jan also dass man kann es
mit können sie sich vielleicht
vorstellen
die schoppe breitet sich aus oder wir
dann differenzierte und das ist ein
fehler
und was hier auch interessant ist ist zu
beobachten dass die tierkörper oder
müssen dass die teile des tierkörpers
oder der tierkörpern in allgemein wird
nichts durch
in der ersten durch die überlieferung
von ewigen tierarten oder tierformen
erklärt wie bei resort ist sondern ist
der sl angeblich entsteht aus
kosmologischen prozesse die sehr
allgemein sind also hier in ungarn und
die elemente und das ist es also wenn
wir einen vergleich in der griechischen
philosophie finden wollen
da von dem was wir gesehen haben
wahrscheinlich dann nicht als opfer
sondern empedokles das werden wir bei
hat das dort liest einfach die idee hat
werth marktwert mensch macht mensch und
jedes blatt hatte der vater und mutter
und das geht einfach in die ewigkeit
zurück und wir brauchen keine keine paar
allgemeine natur für solche theorie und
zu erklären warum die einzelne tier
halten so ausschauen wie sie ausschauen
in dieser tradition und auch bei
empedokles haben wir die idee dass die
tierkörper aus ein prozess eine beim
allgemeinen prozess entstehen wo
kosmische kräfte gegeneinander und
miteinander wirken und dann diese
eigenschaften des einzelnen tieres
ursachen würde erklären
natürlich kann niemand sagen dass das
eine nicht dass andere ausschließt man
könnte sagen und es würde zb jahres
sagen meinen natürlich wenn ein baby
tritt erwartet man dass das baby ein
berg ist aber bei des sockels dass alles
was er sagen also es bereits kann wie
ein fremdkörper körper fusioniert aber
die natur des wertes wird einfach von
der von einer anderen natur erklärt
nämlich die natur die schon in einem
anderen pferd anwesen war werden wir
hier einen eine erzählung oder erklärung
haben wieso verschiedene tierarten und
überhaupt entstehen
in dieser mann könnte es ja sich auch
hier vielleicht fragen inwiefern
menschen dann ähnlich behandelt werden
zum beispiel sind da zum menschen auch
tiere in der chinesischen tradition und
da diese frage so weit wie sein könnte
ist schwer zu beantworten weil das wort
hier nichts offensichtlich ein sehr
altes chinesisches übersetzbar ist also
etwas von dem natürlich kann ich kein
chinesischer um dem was ich gelesen habe
gibt es mehrere wird die man für tiere
einsetzen kann und die sind oft entweder
breiter als tier von der bedeutung her
oder enger
zum beispiel gibt es das wort schenk und
das ist ein wort für ein tier opfer für
eine ritual und die das tier heißt
erschien nachdem das tier ausgesucht
wird und ihr opfer zu werden
würde man dieses wort mit das wort mit
dem wort ihr übersetzten wahrscheinlich
schon aber es offensichtlich viel enger
als mit dem von der bedeutung her als
tier in der auf deutsch und dann gibt es
andere leute die breite sind also heißen
so mehr soll es die wesen oder so oder
die wörter werden anders im handel in
verschiedenen texten hergenommen
wie gesagt das kann ich nicht so
pauschal sagen aber allein die frage ist
110 menschen haustiere ist das irgendwie
voraus dass wir wissen was tier heißt
und das ist nicht ganz so klar dass
dabei die ich sehen könnte trotzdem
finden wir schon texte die ähnlichkeiten
oder gemeinsamkeiten zwischen tieren und
menschen dann voraussetzen und vor allem
texte die dann die konstatieren dass
menschen und jede durch blut und je
dann kritisiert sind nicht nicht dass
alle tiere blut haben
aber es gibt eine große gattung von
menschen bei von wesen die blut und
haben das ist irgendwie tier ist die
gattung von tier oder nahe tragen und
man man liest oft dass all das alle
wesen die blutung haben irgendwie andere
gemeinsamkeiten dadurch haben zum
beispiel eine von den konfuzianischen
philosophen dies später gestatten werde
sagt ich habe die übersetzung nur auf
englisch aber ich will es einfach
einfach ins deutsche übersetzen
alle alben alle lebewesen zwischen
himmel und erde die blut und atem haben
also blut und key müssen auch bewusst
sein
alles was bewusst ist liebt das eigene
also überhaupt keine so liest das was
ihm ähnlich ist
selbst bei kleinen wesen zum beispiel
die spalten wird weinen wenn sie sehen
dass eine andere schwalbe gestorben ist
das ist vielleicht traurig oder und
unter diesen wesen die blut und kitas
sitzen keiner hat besseres verständnis
als der mensch deswegen soll der mensch
seine eltern auch lieben
bis zum tag seines todes ok also die
idee ist dass wir eine gemeinsamkeit
unter allen tieren einschließlich
menschen beobachten
interessanterweise ist wer diese garten
genauso aus genauso beschrieben wie
gesagt habe also die die diversen die
blut und key haben und die gemeinsamkeit
in diesem fall ist dass sie gerade hier
die familienmitglieder setzen und daraus
zieht er die
ist den sehr kompliziert schluss dass
man die nächste familie blieb mitglieder
dann eher ehren und schätzen soll also
wenn es soll schon der vögel der vogel
weint weil seine eltern gestorben sind
sondern würde das auch machen das nur
ein beispiel
und was auch an der an der missetat
interessant ist ist die annahme dass
tiere auch denken also dass sie so etwas
wie selbstbewusstsein oder sowas
indirekten haben und das ist auch nicht
untypisch für andere texte die auch
sagen dass tiere da sie tut und keeper
sitzen dass tiere auch entweder
bewusstsein haben oder dass sie wissen
dass setzen und das ist auch irgendwie
naheliegend ich meine wenn man tiere der
anstalt man sieht dass sie in der lage
sind sachen zu erkennen zum beispiel
beute so erkennen oder die wir
besprochen haben nester oder ein
spinnennetz zu bauen also das ein
zeichen von verständnis und wissen und
deswegen sagen diese texte dass der
mensch dadurch gekennzeichnet ist dass
er denken kann oder dass er wissen hat
wie wir in der alten tradition gesehen
haben sondern dadurch einfach dadurch
dass er das besser machen kann oder dass
er es merkt machen kann
mehr die portfolios als beiersdorf
wiesen dies zurück
interessanterweise und das wird auch
irgendwie durch eine physikalische
theorie erklärt nämlich dass dieses
prinzip das ist ein geist oder
lebenskraft in dem mensch ist feiner
oder reiner als das was wir in den
tieren finden oder ein anderes ein
anderer ausdruck dass den wir finden ist
sagt dass er einen einen raffinierten
geist in jinshan hat im vergleich zu
tieren
vielleicht deswegen oder vielleicht
nichts haben wir auf viele geschichten
und legenden über tiere die besonders
männlich sind weil sie verschiedene
handlungen arten dann zeigen die wir mit
mit der menschheit normalerweise
verbinden würden oder sogar mit ethisch
guter menschlichen handlungen verbinden
würden und das kind mit qualität sondern
für irgendwelche einzelne tierarten
interessanterweise scheint es dabei sein
dass der rabe sehr beeindruckend war aus
sicht der alten chinesin
es gibt mehrere gedichte und legenden
über haben
vielleicht weil sie definitiv unter
anderem weil sie beobachtet haben dass
der habe seine kinder futtert dadurch
dass er irgendwie so aufbringt und das
dem kind gibt also diese und sie haben
auch die waren auch überzeugt dass abend
andere curry die wir gelesen haben dann
traurig geworden sind und sie haben das
beobachtet und anscheinend das haben und
andere folgen andere tiere im
allgemeinen
dann zahlt werden wenn wir der
familienmitglieder stärken
zum beispiel haben wir dieses gedicht
das werde ich war einfach die deutsche
die englische übersetzungen vorlesen bei
dieser schöne ist dass es das heißt
sowohl wollen oder humanität
hauptkämpfer konfuzianische also gibt es
dieses diese stücke
praktisches feature center product
manager in very much is the way of
humans so lebt genau wie ein mensch
interessant auch affen es gibt aber
verschiedene als allem über affen und
wie moralisch gut sie sein können
natürlich sind diese geschichten
gedichte und so weiter so gedacht dass
die wie der diese tat dieses sagt von
arx insel die eine idee hier ist
sicherlich dass wir einfach die menschen
als vorbild bitten die tiere als vorbild
für menschliche handlungen nehmen
sondern also selbst der rabe schätzt
seine eltern wie könnten wir das nicht
machen andererseits setzt natürlich
voraus dass das wirklich passiert und
dass tiere von solche handlungen
sie sind weg solche handlungen
auszuführen
also vielleicht sollten wir versuchen
die die reputation der rabe hier in
dessen zu verbessern aber wir zwei
sachen die sie davon von der vorlesung
einnehmen sollen dass die akten von
konfuzius wichtig ist und das raten
nicht so schlimm sind
danke dann wollte ich wirklich als
brücke zu kümmern sie das muss auch
sagen dass tiere wichtig in der antiken
literatur in china waren und dass sie
wichtig in der region im zusammenhang
des rituals vor allem also die npd der
punkt mit literatur ist eines mit conti
kurs zu eng verbunden weil conti zu es
mehrere werke geschrieben hat unter
anderem werke die einfach kombinationen
ältere literatur waren also als dichtung
und er hat eine sammlung von hin gelobt
die gitter in der sammlung gelobt weil
man so viel wissen über tiere davon
entnehmen konnte und da diese so
genannte klassiker die militärische
literarische klassiker so wichtig waren
gab es auch werke die dazu gewendet
waren diese ältere texte zu verstehen
unter anderem dadurch dass sie die
terminologie erklären
dann könnte man sich vorstellen wenn man
mit seitliches gedicht auf deutsch hatte
würde man vielleicht ein lexikon
brauchen wo man denn lesen kann was die
worte bedeuten die nicht mehr
ganic cent oder in der englischen
sprache shakespeares chance englischer
weise hier gab es dann lexika die die
wörter die technologie beschrieben unter
anderem tier terminologie und deswegen
das ist vielleicht sogar dessen erste
was wir in der chinesischen tradition
haben soziologische bergwerke die tier
terminologie erklären und diese alte
ältere literatur dann darzustellen und
zu erklären
also dass es einen zusammenhang wollt
ihr vorkommen was für könnte es mir sehr
wichtig ist bei konfuzianismus von
anfang an so viel mit diesen
literarischen klassikern zu tun hatte
und dann der andere grund oder die
andere verbindung ist ritual und das
jetzt noch uns nochmal an themen die wir
in indien und griechenland entdeckt
haben wo tiere geschlachtet werden weil
sie für die götter geopfert werden und
dann werden sie gegessen
es gibt mehrere berichte und anekdoten
über konfuzius die mit opfer zu tun
haben wie viel er das schätzt und er ist
hier kein keine ausnahme er war selbst
bürokrat oder wahrscheinlich also der
untersten ebene der bürokratie oder der
gelehrten der richtigen china ist einer
zeit und tiere waren in der antike
bekannt später sehr wichtig zum beispiel
es gab an produziere oder bekannte
stellen für für beamten die nur für eine
tierart zuständig waren
so also der auxmoney ist der der die
ochsendorf schaut dass die ochsen alle
gesund sind und dass die osten dann für
als opfer vorbereitet werden
es gab offizielle die nur daran um die
offerte zu machen damit sie geschlachtet
werden konnten und so weiter und so fort
also der vögel offiziell usw und das
heißt dass man könnte vielleicht sogar
sagen dass die dass das system dieses
bereiches der bürokratie das system der
natur oder der gattungen von tieren dann
geschildert hat vorgespiegelt hat also
für jede tierart ein offizier in der
bürokratie ist die bürokratie ist im
allgemeinen ein spiegelbild der
äußerlichen welt und das trifft auch
hier im fall von
die herren haben es bleibt ein
interessantes thema was man in der
chinesischen pluscity oder politischen
klasse die allgemein beobachtet und wie
gesagt war kann 40 es auch selbst er
hatte sehr viel interesse für ritual im
allgemeinen tores nie und führt ihr
opfer im westen insbesondere erstens
kann man sagen das ritual wirklich ein
zentraler begriff ist in seiner flüssig
und es gibt zitate von ihm woher
praktisch sagt dass man alles machen
muss also im leben muss man alles machen
mit hinblick auf die rituale
also man sozusagen wenn man die straße
entlang geht soll man realistisch
entlang gehen und man gewinnt aus diesen
geschichten den eindruck dass er dass er
ziemlich pingelig war und aus guten
gründen zum beispiel also ein
lieblingszitat von mehr über ihn ist
dass er seinen er würde nichts nützen
aber nicht bereits zu setzen also dass
seine marke gerade war also wenn seine
sätze ein bisschen verlegt war würde
sich nicht hinsetzen er würde das zuerst
gerade machen dann setzen ja aber er hat
alles so gemacht unter anderem an die
opfer und er war es gibt wie gesagt
mehrere antworten wo er ausdrücklich die
opfer unterstützt zum beispiel sagte er
dass auch wenn jemand ein tier in ein
als opfer nicht nutzen will würde die
gotte das tier gerne haben also in
implizieren dass sollte man offen und es
gibt ein
schöne geschichte vielleicht nicht aus
der perspektive des tieres aber es gibt
eine aussagekräftige geschichte übrigens
wo ein mann der mittel redet nicht
bereit ist sein schaf zu opfern ist
nicht ganz klar warum vielleicht weil
das schaf so wertvoll ist oder
vielleicht werden weil er mitleid hat
anders aber wahrscheinlich weil es
schaffen und so wertvoll ist und dann
sagt er so was wie für sie ist das schaf
zu schade für mich ist das ritual zu
schade
oder sie können das land nichts das
zitat die ich würde das eine übersetzung
einer englischen übersetzung wir
gewinnen habe sie können das lernen
nicht ich das ritual nicht also für sie
ist die situation
das allerwichtigste und das ist
interessant war weil man sieht dass für
ihn ritual wirklich ein system ein
normatives system bildet was nicht
unbedingt mit den normalen gebrauch oder
sittens eine gesellschaft über
überschneidet tatsächlich am meter am
ende einer dick de asti die in seiner
zeit praktisch im abgang
danach hat man die sogenannte zeit der
krieg staaten abhängig heißt es immer
time of your stage und er hat sehr stark
gespürt dass seine zeit eine zeit der
unruhe und politisches kritische
unordnung war und er hat dagegen
reagiert dass er gelernt hat dass jeder
einzelne person ordnung dann einsetzen
soll
und ritual dann folgendes wie die alten
es gemacht haben und die also die man
man kann vielleicht denken dass er
irgendwie
herbert thiel ist aber er ist irgendwie
revolution eher konservativ also zurück
zu alten seiten kennen wo alles richtig
gemacht würde
was jetzt nicht mehr der fall ist und
kritisiert die moralische hätten
seinerzeit weil sie nichts damit
übereinstimmen und schwierig glaube ich
für die für mindestens bedient für die
allen menschen die mit konfuzius
gesprochen haben
schwierig weiß zu sehen wann es richtig
war die nur das normale gebrauch weiter
einzusetzen und wann man es sagen eine
andere abstrakte normativität einsetzen
sollte zum beispiel an eine andere
schöne anekdote über hin ist dass jemand
sagt gesagt in meinem dorf sind die
menschen sehr fromm und sehr typen haft
weil ich gebe dir ein beispiel ein mann
hat hat gelernt dass sein vater ein
schaf gestohlen hat noch mal ein schaf
oder so wichtig führt ihr bloß wie aber
in dem wissenschaft und er hat dann der
regierung gesagt dass sein vater ein
gibt war zur france sind sie bei mir wo
ich herkomme und konfuzius sagt das ist
interessant in meinem dorf sind die
leute sorgen dass sie ihre eltern
schützen
das ist sehr typisch typische anekdote
von konfuzius und die und man sieht dass
er auch dass er wirklich in diesem
zusammenhang erst ihr opfer unterstützt
das für ihn wichtig es gab auch die
anekdote liebe ihn dass er hat sich
immer natürlich sehr höflich für alle
geschenke bedankt aber nur verein
geschenkt hat er sich gebeugt nämlich
wenn er fleisch von einem tier opfer
geboten würde also dass das geschenk was
bei ihnen damit das war irgendwie das
beste geschenk aller geschenke aus
seiner sicht und im allgemeinen kommen
tiere oft in den allerletzten vor in
einem zusammenhang wo er betont dass
menschen wichtiger sind als tiere zum
beispiel gibt es eine andere geschichte
wo ein bär der stall brands und er fragt
nicht wie es den werden gegangen ist
sondern nur ob alle menschen dann in
sicherheit gekommen sind also die pferde
sind
der punkt ist die pferde zelle nicht nur
die menschen zählen vielleicht meinen
weiß natürlich nie was der punkt ist
aber das könnte der punkt sein oder ich
weiß es nicht
oder jemand fragt ihn wenn du so weise
bist wieso sollst du nicht alleine damit
und dann sagt er ich bin ein mensch mit
wem sonst soll ich wohnen soll ich
draußen mit den tieren leben also mit
den vögeln und tieren
nein ich bin ein mensch ich bin sozial
ich brauche meine soziale menschliche
beziehungen oder es gibt eine geschichte
wo
männer dann eine frau gemeint gemeinsam
haben
und das heißt dass man nicht weiß von
wem die kinder sense und die konfusion
fanden dass das ist nicht diese können
bis jetzt aber die könnten sie dann
erfahren dass ganz schlimmen das sagten
dass es sie wenn man es dass diese
männer haben sich wie tiere genommen sie
sollen umgebracht werden damit in der
lage die menschen zu werden fanden sich
hingegen entwickle wie bestien wirklich
angenommen also und auch kann man sagen
dass das eine zentrale rolle in der
komplizierten heftig von wie gesagt
menschlichen beziehungen gespielt ist
aber fünf beziehungen im besonderen
nämlich herrscher untertan vater sohn
bruder bruder aber das heißt also wir
brüder brüder
wir haben eines für links bruder in den
tischen zwillingsbruder
ich bin aber der junge also zehn minuten
jünger aber ich bin sonst der jüngere
bruder und das soll ich dann immer im
kopf behalten anscheinend kam man frau
also ehemann ehefrau und freundesfreunde
und diese von beziehungen sind die
zentrale beziehungen für konfuzius und
genau wie man realistisch alles machen
soll
soll man ein ds linie diese beziehungen
virtuelles leben noch mal kommen tiere
hier als gegenbeispiel vor der konfuzius
gesagt hat heutzutage denken die leute
dass es genügt wenn sie ihre eltern nur
futter also essen für die
der eltern besorgen aber das ist was die
tiere machen das genügt nicht
also wird die menschliche menschliche
waren eltern muss man erden und wirklich
mit hingabe behandeln und nicht einfach
so behandelt wie die tiere jede eltern
behandeln und von daher könnte man
vielleicht entnehmen dass mit nur das
konfuzius keine karte sondern dass er
keine tätig haben könnte das heißt er
kann und will nichts erklären wie wir
ethische pflicht tieren gegenüber haben
weil wir menschen sind und weil wir bei
unserer ethische klicken nur mit
menschlichen beziehungen zu tun haben
können
ist das der fall nein eigentlich nicht
erstens vielleicht gehen wir zurück zu
dieser diesem beispiel mit der matte er
ist jetzt nicht auf die matte wenn die
martin nicht perfekt gerade ist also das
heißt er behandelt die matte irgendwie
respektvoll
oder er will mit der matte so umgehen
dass sein verhalten passend ist
man könnte fast sagen ästhetisch perfekt
aber perfekt und natürlich soll man auch
tiere so behandeln
das heißt nicht unbedingt dass wir
ethische pflicht tieren gegenüber haben
aber wir haben im allgemeinen die
pflicht alles so zu behandeln wie es
behandelt werden soll und das den
formaten es gibt auch für machen
es gibt also alle tierarten und es gibt
ab gibt auch für die opfer also er sagt
zum beispiel wenn man ein tier aber
unternimmt und das falsch macht zum
beispiel um der die falsche zeit das
zelt nicht und das ist nichts womit im
allgemeinen wall street sehr wichtig
alles gleichzeitig zu machen es sogar
der meister der der rechtzeitigkeit zu
einem händler hast du dir vorgenommen
würde und allein daran sehen wir dass er
nicht dafür war und auch nicht dafür
sein könnte hier einfach so ist über
handeln wie es uns gefällt oder wie also
wie zb wie wir es lustig finden oder
besser
man muss die materie und die natur im
allgemeinen respektvoll und ritual
realistisch in diesem sinn behandeln
weil man das einfach allgemein machen
soll
man könnte sagen dass die das haut ihre
und dem ethischen prinzip von wohlwollen
oder einfach so gut sein
in der terminologie rein heißt also man
muss jugendhaft mit tieren umgehen genau
wie man tun hat mit menschen umgeht
allerdings ist es ganz klar dass die
haupt beziehungen die wir haben mit
anderen menschen sind und dass wir
bestimmte beziehungen zu bestimmte
menschen haben die wichtiger sind als
beziehungen zu anderen menschen und als
beziehungen zu tiere also wenn man alle
menschen gleich behandeln würde oder
wenn man tiere sogar an
also zehn menschen werden werden wir
ganz weit vom konfuzianismus weg und
jetzt kommen wir jetzt komme ich zurück
zumal es muss wurde über die frage
gestellt erklärt weil die meisten waren
dafür
wie gesagt dass man in der vor allem der
in der im politischen zusammenhang dass
man einfach zu den allgemeinen gut
schaut also das was für die ganze
gesellschaft gesellschaft - voll ist und
wichtig und die konvention haben gesagt
nein weil das an
das unterminiert und unsere ganze hektik
weil man sie richtig sagt behandele
jeden mensch genau richtig und die
richtigkeit entsteht dadurch dass man
eine bestimmte beziehung zu diesem
mensch hat und was sie was ihnen ein
neues mussten nicht gefallen hat ist
dass man anscheinend die eltern genauso
gut behandeln soll
die irgendjemand die das wollten
übrigens die meisten gar nichts sagen
natürlich bei und das müssen sie auch
nicht sagen weil sie können auch
natürlich anerkennen dass es für die
gesellschaft gut ist wenn kinder auf
ihre eltern aufpassen aber trotzdem ist
mindestens die begründung anderes war
dem die meisten müssen sagen dass kinder
auf ihre eltern aufpassen müssen weil es
für die gesellschaft gut ist wenn man
die für die alte nach sorgues werden die
konfusion sagen nein es geht um diese
beziehung also die beziehung ist die
quelle der normativität das ist nicht
eine folge einer normativen terry und
deswegen diese spannung zwischen neues
maß an kondition es muss meines
erachtens wird kondition es muss aber
für tätig erst richtig spannend wenn wir
menschen sie erreichen
valencias eine ethische theorie hat die
man in der tierethik
und anwenden könnte hat er aber nicht
gemacht senders das im 9er
konfuzianismus gemacht wird ok nancy
sind zwei konfuzianische philosophen aus
der spät aus der antike wie ich vorher
gesagt habe und natürlich könnte man
vielleicht ich aber man könnte sehr viel
über sie erzählen die die grundlegende
gegenüberstellung die man immer macht
ist dass sie zwei verschiedene
auffassungen der menschlichen natur
hatten
wenn sie es will behaupten dass die
menschliche natur an sich gut ist oder
mindestens gute tendenzen hat die wir
pflegen können und als wurzel oder samen
hernehmen können um die tugend zu
entwickeln
und er hat ein berühmtes beispiel dann
nämlich wenn man sieht dass ein kind
dabei es in einen brunnen zu fallen wird
jeder mensch sofort denken dass erhalten
muss nicht weil er daran freude hat oder
weil er befürchtet dass das dorf in den
verspottet wenn ein itf er wird einfach
automatisch spontan zu reagieren und
diese diese instinkte könnte man sagen
so helfen oder mitleid zu haben mit
gefühl zu haben dass es wie gesagt die
wurzel der tugend für menschen und es
ist fast was zu sagen aber es gibt eine
geschichte kommentars die genau diese
idee dann hast wird mit dem mit dem
beispiel eines tieres und das wollte ich
dann vorlesen das ist eine alte deutsche
übersetzung von der passage die ich
gefunden habe
menschen sprach sie habe von hh erzählen
hören der könig habe einst in seinem
sack gelassen dass einer der einen
ochsen führte unten am see vorbei
gekommen
der könig habe ich die szene gefragt
wohin mit dem ochsen
man habe erwidert es soll zu blocken
weil geschlachtet werden
da habe der könig gesagt lasst ihn
laufen ich kann es nicht mit ansehen wie
er so ängstlich zittert wie einer der
unschuldige zum richtplatz geführt wird
und dann jetzt überschwemmen dessen aber
dann sagt der könig schlag der einfach
ein schaf stattdessen eine office hatte
weniger wertvoller als ein schaf und
dann kommt mensch ist mehr wert als der
fall so dass herr spart geld zusammen
dadurch dass er das schaf bringen lässt
anstatt anpassen manchester hat die
siege sind dann sagt menschen manche
werden denken sie haben das nur gemacht
mit sparsam zu sein aber sie haben es
doch aus mitleid für den boxen gemacht
oder und der könig gesagt ja dann sagt
man tschüs die siege sind genügt und
könig der welt zu werden
die leute dachten alle es sei nur
sparsamkeit von euch gewesen aber ich
weiß bestimmt dass er es nicht hat mit
ansehen können das doch hat ihr nicht
anders gehandelt also wenn er wirklich
nur so sparsam gewesen wäre wie die
leute meint er hat besser wissen sollten
wenn ihr mitleid haltet mit der unschuld
diesem ritt platz geführt würde
was ist dass die sich für einen
unterschied zwischen einem ochsen in
einem scharf gute putts es war aber
jetzt geht es ans es war dennoch ein
zeichen von melden
er sagt den osten aber hatte das schaden
nicht gesehen
es geht den gebildeten mit
hier nun einmal so wenn er sie leben
gesehen hat hannes karner nichts zu
sehen wie sie getötet werden
und wenn er sie hat schwein herrn bringt
er es nicht über sich er fleisch zu
essen dass es ja auch der grund warum
die gebildete sich von der küche fern
hält
okay das kommt uns allen natürlich
bekannt vor aber der der punkt hier ist
nichts so sei zu erklären warum es so
wenig vegetarier gibt es der punkt ist
es sein dass der könig irgendwie richtig
war weil diese milde oder mitleid ein
dass es sozusagen eine unentwickelte
phase der moralität und dann später sagt
er
nun ist eure milde so groß dass sie sich
oft ihre erstreckt und doch reicht ihre
wirkung nicht zu eurem volk wie ist denn
das nur also erst deswegen sagt er
diese gesinnung genügt und können der
welt zu werden hält es aber mit könig
der welt und kann es nicht werden weil
sein mitleid nicht weit genug geht
also soll mit leid vor allem für andere
menschen haben und nicht nur für diesen
einen ochsen ballerinen gesehen hat und
gesehen wie erzittert wirklich eine sehr
interessante passage natürlich und da
sieht man dass man dass er diese ins die
tiefe dass dieses instinktives mitleid
was für tiere haben will ihn moralisch
sehr bedeutendes ist natürlich genug
nichts aber es hat eine starke
verbindung mit zum beispiel den
beziehungen die wir mit
familienmitglieder haben sorgen
also diese dieses gefühls pflegen dass
es beim nzxt sagt genau das gegenteil
nämlich dass die menschliche neigung
schlecht wirst ein gebäude natürliche
neigung und für ihn hat jeder mensch die
neigung
andere leute auszubeuten wenn man diese
neigung folgt wird man einfach räuber da
wird man nicht gut da wird man schlecht
und deswegen muss man das überwinden und
die tugend entwickelt gerade dadurch
dass man künstlich gebildet und bildung
und gute handlung lernt also ist genauso
zu sagen gegen die menschliche natur
wenn man gut ist
anstatt mit der menschlichen natur wie
man's ja sagte trotzdem ist es für beide
denke die folge dass man am ende die die
richtige typen haft in beziehung die die
dackel zählt ist mit anderen menschen
und nicht mit tieren zb sagte münchens
wenn man keinen vater hat dass es da
sieht man wie ein tier also die die
beziehungen die wir mit anderen menschen
zu haben das was uns als menschen
ausmacht so lange dass wir die
beziehungen gut führen also die wenn wir
so leben wie konfuzius dann
vorgeschlagen hat und hat folgen hat das
heißt wenn wir realistisch die
menschliche beziehungen dann ausführt
erst dann sind wir gut
als menschen und deswegen sagte sind sie
dass die das habe ich auf der hand der
unterschied zwischen menschen und tieren
ist dass die menschen diese
künstliche beziehungen dann ein film ein
bisschen irgendwie künstlich ich bin ich
zum beispiel mann und frau sind nicht
künstlich dass wir diese zwei
geschlechter geschäfte haben aber was
die menschen machen ist nicht das was
die tiere machen zb die menschen leben
getrennt männer und frauen oder essen
gezeigt zum beispiel und das sind sie
sehr gut das ist das ein beispiel von
dem was die tiere nicht machen dass du
dich führen nicht diese künstliche
unterscheidungen 1
und diese künstlichen konnte scheidungen
haben als gipfel das ritual also er sagt
die höchsten unterscheidungen sind
gesellschaftlich die höchsten
gesellschaftlichen unterscheidungen sind
die rituale
also das ist was uns als menschen
ausmacht hier können wir das wir haben
vorher in der küche nicht gesehen dass
zb von uns das wichtigste der ethik ist
weiters uns als menschen kennzeichnen
für sie werden die menschheit wirklich
durch ritual gekennzeichnet mindestens
ist das das beste was uns als menschen
ausmacht
im gegensatz zu tieren die natürlich
keine ritual hinaus führen und am ensi
es hat auch gehen nicht zur weiteren
direkten natürlich weil er eben die
jugend in diese in diese tendenz für
mitleid wurzelt die man auch für tiere
haben kann und soll
trotzdem liegen ganz klar dass wir
menschen und tieren mit gleich behandeln
sollen
also erstens verschiedene menschen nicht
gleich es kommt darauf an welche
beziehungen zu den mensch hat und hier
der gar netzen und deswegen sagt er dass
wir bei tieren fürsorge zeigen sollen
bei menschen sollen wir rennen einsetzen
wollten sowieso in der provinz sein wie
man auf englisch sagen würde
und bei manchen menschen sollen
als wohlwollend sein man soll sogar
hingabe zeiten zum beispiel für die
eigenen eltern für die eigenen eltern
war es mal jemand in den kinder haben
können sie das herr dort mit geben und
sagen ja das ist die wichtige theorie ok
also was jetzt haben wir gesehen dass
die wilson einem möglichen tätig sind in
der antiken in dem antiken kondition
ismus anwesend aber ist es an das ist
auffällig dass sie das nicht so weit
gebracht haben wie man es könnte aber in
nur neo konfuzianismus wird das viel
weitergebracht ist die erreichen
natürlich nie eine theorie wo tiere und
menschen gleichgesetzt werden die
matches gesagt hat es liegt in der natur
dass die sachen und gleich sind und das
ist für alle kommt 40 jahren ist er
nicht nur der fall sondern wirklich
zentral aber erstens setzt sie menschen
menschenleere über die menschliche natur
besser durch als die lehre von klenze
und zweitens breiten sie diese idee des
mitleids aus unter anderem weil sie eine
kosmologie entwickeln wollen alle wurden
die ganze natur eine einheit bildet und
das ist sehr stark zum beispiel bei sieg
sie ein paar neue konditionen ist aus
dem zwölften jahrhundert er ist sagt zum
beispiel dass menschen obwohl sie den
stark stärksten geist haben nicht
alleine im universum steht ist sein
geist ist auch derjenige von den tieren
und vögeln und sogar von den pflanzen
das erinnert natürlich an ideen der welt
zähle die wir bei platon gesehen haben
und die wir mittelalte nochmal sehen
werden
also die diese gelb das vielleicht das
ganze universum oder kosmos ein tier ist
oder mindestens eine natürliche einheit
die eine die einen geist teilt das haben
wir auch in der chinesischen tradition
interessanterweise aber es ist auch
interessant ist dass er zitiert dieses
beispiel mit dem kind und dem brunnen
und dann sagt er und der gebildete hat
sogar diese tendenz wenn er ameisen
sieht die gefahr sind also ein art zu
sagen eine ameise dicke die gleiche in
den brunnen fällt würde genauso hat den
weißen wirken wie ein kind
er würde sofort instinktiv spontan die
ameise retten und er hat auch diese
diese ideen aufgenommen
die biggesee namen schon sehr lang an
will in der operation anwesend waren
nämlich dass menschen in deutschland
dass tiere auch tugendhaftes leben
können also dass sie ihre eltern gut
behandeln usw
und er hat wirklich sehr stark gemacht
dass die telefonate vorbilder sind also
in macon für zynismus haben wir wirklich
eine tendenz die implizite tier hätte
weiter zu entwickeln die wir ein
kompliziertes haben und die die wurzeln
der normativität in der menschlichen
handlungen mit der würze der natürlichen
handlung der tieren zu identifizieren
das ist immer das der weg ist die natur
zu folgen
ob man hier ist oder ob man mensch
natürlich hat der das tier eine anti der
natur und deswegen einen anderen weg als
wir aber die normative erklärung ist
gleich bei tieren
das ist wirklich interessant und ist
eine idee die wir auch in anderen
installationen werden dieser vorlesung
muss her sehen
okay das war das alles was ich über
chinesischen zirkus meist wenn nicht
mehr als ich weiß das ist alles was ich
darüber glaube ich dass da gewissen ich
sagte ihm blieb das weiß dass es nicht
jetzt viel versprochen ich werde jetzt
zehn minuten verwenden